Savory sweet and bold the smells envelop
you as you walk into the small kitchen
of Shea Shamus this Cuttery breakfast
Feast is served no matter the hour it
features a Bedouin bread made of flour
and water called reg gag and flavorful
stew called marguga
shamsal kasabi's restaurant in sukhwakif
is also a landmark she is the first
woman to own a Eatery in Qatar and the
first to open a business in the soup
hospitality and generosity are pillars
of the Qatari Traditions women play a
role at home when we open our doors and
welcome our neighbors and visit us with
traditional food here I will be a true
representative of the Qatari women
more than 20 years ago kasabi began
pickling lemons in her backyard and
selling them via Word of Mouth then she
opened a spy shop and eventually this
restaurant in 2014. along the way her
entrepreneurial Ambitions clashed with
her family's ideas about A Woman's Place
in the past as a conservative Society it
was difficult for women to socialize
with men I was the first to bend the
rule with some objections from my family
How could a woman work among men
kasabi's customers include the Cuttery
ruling family Foodies and footballer
David Beckham her home style cooking in
an Arab coffee shop environment is a
link to qatar's Roots
my main goal is to ensure that our
Cuisine lives on for future Generations
it's part of preserving our cultural
Traditions not only for qataris but for
visitors to our country especially since
Qatar is hosting the World Cup
last summer kasabi launched an online
store now with these jars of spices and
mixes she can share a taste of Qatar
with the world